The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --the
back of the room.
This course is being taped.
It may appear in the
future on EdX or MITx.
It will appear on
OpenCourseWare.
So that means that by just
sitting in the classroom,
you're choosing to participate
in this adventure of having
the course videotaped.
If you want to hide, you
can sit in the back row.
If you want to be part of the--
if you want to be famous,
sit in the front row.
So I handed out the syllabus.
And I'll just go through
some of the things on here.
So as a prerequisite--
so at MIT, we have three quantum
field theory courses, 1, 2, 3.
As a prerequisite, I've listed
quantum field theory two.
I don't want to stop people
that are taking quantum field
theory 3 this term from also
registering for this course.
But some of the things
that you'd usually
see in quantum
field theory 3 are
kind of important background
things for this course.
So what I've done is I've posted
on the website for the course
my lecture notes from when
I taught quantum field
theory 3 last year.
So you can look at that.
And I'll assign some reading
for that as background material
for this.
Some things actually were
taught in quantum field theory 2
last term, some things
like, for example,
the beta function of QCD
for normalization group.
So those things are going to
be important prerequisites
for this course.
And I'll assign some
background reading
so that you can remind
yourself about those things.
If you have any concerns
about your preparation,
please feel free to talk to me.
In terms of grading,
this is pretty low key.
We have five problem
sets that will
be roughly every two weeks.
We won't start the first
problem set until next week.
And then there'll
be a presentation
at the end of the class.
There's no exams, no tests.
The purpose of the
presentation is basically,
effective field theory
is a very broad topic
and there's no chance
we'll be able to cover
every possible thing
about effective field
theory in this course.
In particular, a
lot of applications
we'll have to be brief on
or we won't touch on at all.
So if you look at the
syllabus on page three,
there's a list of possible
presentation topics.
Each one of you will pick--
each one of you that
registers for the course
and wants to give a presentation
will give a presentation
at the end on one
of these topics,
prepare it, and stand up
and lecture to the class.
And the idea is
that basically you
will teach the class for
half an hour or so about one
of these topics,
and then that way we
will broaden the scope of things
that we'll be able to cover.
Even this long list
is not complete.
And you can also pick a
topic that's not on this list
if you talk to me about it.
So a little later I'll also give
you some suggested references
for reading about this.
I just, at this point,
give you the list.
And we'll talk about where you
might read about these things
later on.
I'll give you a more
detailed handout.
So even if you just
look at this list,
you kind of see the breadth
of-- the idea of effective field
theory, how broadly it impacts
physics, and particle physics,
in particular.
So you know, everything
from finite temperature QCD,
finite density, effective
field theories in inflation,
popular these days.
Effective field
theories of cold atoms,
are also very
popular these days.
Non-relativistic QCD production
of quarkonia, both in medium,
out of medium.
Relativistic super fluids.
Conformal effective
field theories.
The list goes on and on.
Lattice effective
field theories.
So it's a very broad topic.
And what I'm going
to do in this course
is I'm going to start out with
the first half of the course
teaching you about the ideas
of effective field theory,
some of the basic
ingredients that
go into all effective
field theories
and some more technical
things that only show up
in some effective
field theories,
but that are kind
of providing you
with lessons if you
had to ever construct
your own effective field theory.
That's the idea of the
first half of the course.
The second half
of the course, I'm
going to focus on a particular
effective field theory--
soft-colinear effective
field theory, which
is an effective field theory
that's close to my heart that's
exciting these days because
of its applications to the jet
physics in the LHC.
So we'll talk about that as
the second half of the course.
So as I say on the
outline, there's not really
a textbook for this course.
I suggest some text
that may be useful,
but they're not any
one of them will
be useful for more than 20%
of the material, many of them
for less than 10%
of the material.
So I don't necessarily
recommend that you go out
and buy all of them--
or buy any of them.
I will try to post
chapters of things
on the website when
it's required reading.
And these books will be
available in the reading room,
so you can do it that
way, if you like.
If you're really serious about
phenomenology, of course,
you should own all these books.
So on the course outline,
I also listed office hours.
And I will adjust those when
I find out all your schedules.
And I also listed
that [INAUDIBLE]
who's sitting in the back,
is a 10% TA for the course.
He'll be doing some
grading for us.
He won't have office hours.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: So I know
that some of you
have registered for the course.
And some of you are
here as listeners.
If you are here is a
listener, I have an add form
and I want you to
add it as a listener,
just so that we have
a record of you,
partly because that
affects the ability
to offer this course
in the future,
also because we're going
to use online tools
and we may even use
some online MITx
tools if I find out that they're
very useful for the course.
So I want you to
be in the system.
And I want you to be able to
access that information if we
end up going that way.
So I think that's it.
So as far as preamble, does
anybody have any questions?
OK.
All right.
So let's start.
So let's start with
the big picture.
I like to say that
the big picture is
that there's interesting
physics at all scales.
What effective field
theory lets you do
is it lets you tease out
this interesting physics
at all scales.
So in particular, you can
focus on a particular scale
and find the interesting
physics there using
the tools of effective
field theory.
Now that's a little different
than how we teach physics.
If you think about drawing a
diagram from your freshman year
to now many of you in graduate
studies about how you learned
physics, it was not
by kind of focusing in
on individual particular
scales, but more
from a kind of
bottom-up point of view.
So I would draw a
picture of how we teach
physics in the following way.
So you start out as a freshman.
You learn classical mechanics.
You learn E&M, classical E&M.
You learn Newtonian gravity.
And then you build
on these things.
These things are
your starting point
and then you build on them.
So you learn quantum
mechanics and that
builds on classical mechanics.
You learn special
relativity, which
is building on both classical
mechanics and electromagnetism.
At some point, you learn general
relativity and quantum field
theory.
And quantum field
theory is synthesizing
quantum mechanics and special
relativity, and then these two
here.
So you think about learning
physics from the bottom
up in this picture.
You learn these things first.
And then you learn these things.
And you sort of
keep synthesizing,
keep putting things together.
We're going to be
doing in this course
the exact opposite of that.
We're going to be taking
one of these blobs--
in particular, this one--
and we're going
to be looking deep
inside it trying to make
more and more specific field
theories.
So if you like, if you
want to draw it as a blob,
we'll be taking quantum
field theory and we'll be
looking for derivatives of it--
or perhaps derivatives
of derivatives of it,
like this-- and figuring out how
to take a very general theory,
like quantum field theory
for the standard model,
and finding things that are more
specific and in some ways more
powerful than just having
the original theory
we started with-- more
powerful in the sense of being
able to do calculations.
So why do we want to do that?
There's a couple of
different reasons--
or why do we do
that, since, as I've
tried to convince you with
the outline of the course
and some of the
presentation topics,
that this is something that
happens all over the place.
So as you go up in this
chart, it actually becomes--
even though you have
a more general theory
and it becomes more beautiful
and you can write down
a synthesis of physics
in fewer lines,
it also becomes harder
to compute things.
So just as an
example, if you just
wanted to compute the
energy spectrum of hydrogen,
and you know very
well that you can
do that in quantum mechanics.
And particularly it's a classic
example, and fairly easy.
If you try to do that
in quantum field theory,
it's much harder,
because quantum field
theory, in some sense, has
too much for that problem.
So that's one example.
Another is the elliptical
orbits of the planets,
which are easier in
Newtonian gravity
than in general relativity.
And these are just two examples.
There's many more
where the field--
one of these blobs may be
too general for actually
tackling the problem that
you want to deal with.
And by focusing in, which
is what effective field
theory allows you to do,
you can get more ability
to compute more accurately
and in a simpler fashion.
So what we want when we think
about effective field theory
is we want the
simplest framework that
captures the essential physics.
We don't want to carry
along for the ride
a whole bunch of
superfluous things
that are not important
for the problem we're
trying to deal with.
But we also don't want
to give up anything.
So we're very demanding.
So even if we're giving up
something in our leading order
description, we want
to retain the ability
to correct that leading
order description--
order by order in
some expansions--
so that we can make it
as precise as we desire.
So I'll say that we can correct
it, in principle, to arbitrary
precision.
So if you like,
what we're doing is
we're taking quantum field
theory and we're expanding it.
And the lowest order
determine that description
is an effective field theory.
And that effective field theory
may have different fields.
It may have
different symmetries.
And it will certainly
have ability
to calculate in a
different fashion
than the original theory.
But we will keep higher order
terms in that expansion.
And therefore, we'll
be able to correct
it to arbitrary precision
just by expanding
to higher and higher order.
So examples of this that
even are familiar here--
non relativistic
expansion, getting back
to non relativistic
quantum mechanics,
or doing a post-Newtonian
expansion in general relativity
to go back towards
Newtonian gravity.
You don't have to stop
at the first term.
You can keep higher-order terms.
And in that way,
you could calculate,
for example, energy
levels in hydrogen
using a non-relativistic
framework that
encodes all the ingredients
of quantum field theory.
Or you could use--
you could look at
the orbit of planets
and relativistic corrections
and general relativistic
corrections by
expanding this theory.
So those are two examples.
So most of the examples that
I've listed on the project list
are the type of
taking quantum field
theory for the standard model.
Some of them involve
gravity, but most of them
involve the standard
model and expanding it
and focusing in on particular
degrees of freedom.
So let's say that we've
picked a physical system
and we want to describe it.
What are the things
that we should
do in order to develop an
effective field theory?
What are the steps?
I should say that I'm going
to post my lecture notes.
So if you don't want to take
notes, you don't have to.
If you'd like to take
notes, feel free.
But I will scan
and post my notes.
So the first thing
you need to do
is figure out what the relevant
degrees of freedom are.
What are the things
that actually
matter for the problem
you want to study?
Sometimes that is
easier than other times.
Sometimes it's
completely obvious.
You want to study some
low energy properties
of the standard model.
You get rid of the
heavy particles.
You keep the light ones.
Fairly straightforward.
Other times it may be
tricky to actually determine
what the relevant
degrees of freedom are.
And people in the field may
even argue about what they are.
So we'll talk about
examples of both types
here throughout the course.
So it sounds trivial,
but it may not be.
You also want to think
about the symmetries.
Sometimes that guides
you in thinking
about the relevant
degrees of freedom.
Sometimes these things
go hand in hand.
But that's certainly
an important ingredient
in developing the
effective field theory.
And you also have to be careful
here, because sometimes you
might have a theory
that has no symmetry,
or doesn't have an
apparent symmetry.
But when you start expanding--
which is what I've argued
you're going to be doing--
when you start expanding, you
may have a symmetry suddenly
appear.
And we'll actually talk
about several examples
of that happening throughout
the course, as well.
So your effective field
theory may have more symmetry
than the theory
you started with.
Because you've
neglected something,
you could have more symmetry.
And the other important
thing is to figure out
what you're expanding in.
And at the same time,
what the leading order
description of the theory is.
What is the lowest
order Lagrangian?
And basically,
these are the things
you have to do to get started.
If this is true, actually,
independent of kind
of what theory
you're talking about,
if you're doing quantum field
theory, what this first one
means is figuring
out what fields
you're going to be using.
The symmetry is
basically guiding you
about the interactions.
If you have gauge
symmetry, then of course
you're going to
write down something
that respects that symmetry.
That's going to tell you
something about the interaction
terms.
And then finally, this
expansion parameters
goes under the rubric of what
is called power counting.
And if you take those
three things together
and you figure out the
leading order description,
then you have an
effective field theory.
You write down he
Lagrangian for it.
You should try to
use some color.
So if you thought about
regular quantum field theory--
for example, for
the standard model--
you'd also do these
first two things.
You figure out what
the fields are.
the interactions are.
But you don't think about
too much about this question,
about the power counting.
And actually, more broadly, in
the field of effective field
theory, this idea here of power
counting is very important.
It's as important as
something like gauge symmetry.
It's really a fundamental
thing about the whole framework
that you're doing.
So in an effective field
theory, power counting
is just as important as figuring
out things like symmetries.
And in particular,
just to make it
sort of clear that
it's important,
I'll compare it
to gauge symmetry.
It's really a fundamental
ingredient in what you're doing
and in the whole theory,
because the power counting
being consistent is actually
necessary for the whole field
theory--
effective field
theory-- to make sense.
OK, so what's the key principle?
Well, there's a key principle
of quantum field theory
that we're using when we design
effective field theories.
And that is that we're
insensitive to physics
at higher energy scales.
So going back to
Wilson, if we're
interested in describing
the physics at some scale
m squared, we don't need to
know the details of physics
at higher energy.
So at scales lambda squared that
are much bigger than m squared,
we don't really need to know
the details of the dynamics that
are going on there.
We don't need to know the
field content, necessarily,
at those scales, or anything
else about the dynamics.
And that is, in some
sense, a key idea
that makes the whole idea
of effective field theory
possible.
I want you to make
sure that you don't
think of this too narrowly.
In the way that I've written,
it's actually a little bit too
narrow, because I said that--
I've described it in
terms of mass scale.
So I've kind of intuited
in your mind something
like a Z' boson or
a W' boson, which
is a heavy particle
from some perspective.
And maybe they treat that
as a heavy particle and I'm
interested--
and let me say it differently.
Say I'm interested
in a light particle,
like the bottom quark.
Then I can get rid of physics at
a heavy scale, like the w mass.
Or if I think about how new
physics impacts precision
electroweak data and that
new physics is heavy,
then I can think about
effective operators.
That's kind of
the intuition I've
given you with the sentence
that I've written here.
But it's actually not--
that's not quite general enough.
And the reason it's not
quite general enough
is that this mentality doesn't
always apply just strictly
to math scales.
If I say this-- m squared much
less than lambda squared-- then
you immediately
think that you're
expanding an m squared
over lambda squared.
And that, of classic
effective field theory,
that's exactly what you do.
You expand in light scales
divided by heavy scales.
They're mass scales.
They're invariant masses.
They're Lorentz
invariant quantities.
That's the most common
thing that you do.
We're going to be doing much
more than that in this course.
We'll be doing-- we'll be
talking about cases where
the power counting is in
situations that are not simply
m squared much less than lambda
squared, but other things--
dimensionless parameters.
So sometimes it will
become more complicated.
But still, this
guiding principle
that there's physics that's
far away, in some sense,
from the physics that you're
interested in, that it can
be removed from the theory when
you're just talking about it,
in that sense, this
is more general.
It's really not just a
strictly one-dimensional thing,
as it would be if I describe
it in terms of mass scales,
but a more general principle.
And I think that
will become clearer
when we actually do examples
where it's not simply
mass scales.
We will, of course, start out
by talking about mass scale,
since that's the classic
thing that most people think
of when they think of
effective field theory.
So can anyone give
me an example--
just to try to get the
class engaged here--
can anyone give me an example of
an effective field theory that
doesn't involve expanding
strictly in mass scales,
involves some other
type of expansion?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, OK.
HQT you can say is
just an expansion
in lambda QCD over MB
or MC, so not quite.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
Well, you've studied it.
But correct answer.
Any other thoughts?
So another example
would be something
like non-relativistic QED.
If you do non-relativistic
QED, you're
actually expanding
in the velocity,
not strictly in the
ratio of mass scales,
although you would think,
for example, non-relativistic
QED would be for a heavy
electron, which is true--
a heavy, massive particle.
That's not what the power
counting expansion is in.
It'll actually be
in the velocity
being much less than
the speed of light.
And that actually
plays an important role
in designing the
effective field theory,
determining what the
leading operators are.
So even something
as simple as going
to higher order
corrections in hydrogen
involves thinking about--
thinking beyond this
simple statement here.
Well, since we're on
the topic of hydrogen,
let me go into a little
more detail there.
So just to flesh this out a
bit and to talk about some
of the things that you
have to be careful about,
I'll phrase an example of
this statement as the fact
that we don't need to
know about bottom quarks
to describe hydrogen.
Well, that's good.
When you took quantum
mechanics as an undergraduate,
you didn't have bottom
quarks in your description.
So if you did need them, you
would have missed something.
What did you have
in your description?
Well, in a quantum
field theory language,
you have this diagram.
You had an electron and a
proton with photon exchange.
And you also, when you thought
about the binding energy,
if we work in units where h bar
and c is 1, which I will always
do, then the binding energy
is 1/2 ME alpha squared.
And if you ask about
the bottom quarks,
the reason that you
didn't need them
is because they were suppressed.
They weren't negligible--
completely negligible--
at least, at the level
of how accurately we
can measure this thing.
Well, they're pretty small.
They're at the 10 to
the minus 8 level.
And that's because
they come in suppressed
by the mass of the
electron squared
over the mass of the
bottom quarks squared.
So how would you think
of them coming in?
Well you'd think of them
coming in through some diagram,
for example, where the bottom
quark couples to the photon
through a vacuum
polarization like that.
And this diagram,
indeed, will give you
corrections of this type.
Now, it's a bit more
subtle than that.
And that's because
a diagram like this
also has other contributions
besides just these ones that I
mentioned here.
So the basic picture
is, indeed, correct
that we can neglect the
bottom quark because it's
giving small corrections.
But there is one subtlety.
And that has to do with the
fact that we have to decide
what we mean by this coupling.
OK.
So from your previous courses
in quantum field theory,
when you learned about
running couplings,
you learned the diagrams
like that one contribute
to running couplings.
And so the B quark, therefore,
can affect the coupling
if you worked in, for
example, the MS bar scheme,
since it contributes to the
running of the coupling.
And in particular, you know for
the electromagnetic coupling,
if you ask about what
that coupling is,
it has a different
value because it runs--
if you evaluate it at a
scale like the W mass,
then it's like 1/128, versus if
you evaluate it at a very low
energy, the electron
mass or below,
then it's the classic 1/137.036.
OK.
So there's some change.
And the bottom quark
is part of what
contributes to that change.
Of course, other particles
are contributing, too.
So if we want to say this
statement about bottom quarks
and we want to state the
conclusions more precisely,
then we would do it this way.
We would say if alpha is a
parameter of the standard model
and we imagine that we
fix it at a high energy--
so we could imagine
that we fixed it
by doing [INAUDIBLE] on physics
in an E plus E minus collider.
But some process that's
a high energy process,
we determine, say, for
example, this value.
If we take that attitude as
how we define the parameter,
then the parameter
that actually matters
for hydrogen, which is this
parameter at the low scale,
does depend on the
bottom quark, because how
we get from the high
scale to the low scale
depends on the fact that
the bottom quark exists.
But we could also take
a different attitude.
And that is we could take
a low energy attitude.
So we could say, let's forget
about doing high energy
physics.
Let's just do low energy
physics and extract
alpha of 0 from some low
energy atomic experiments.
And if that's the way that
we define the parameter,
then the value can be
used in other experiments.
And we never have to
know anything about MB.
So we didn't really have to
know about the high energy--
about the higher energy
theory unless we actually
were doing some
experiments up there.
Is there any
questions about that?
Good.
So if we want to write
an equation for that,
what it means is that
when you integrate out
particles like the B quark,
remove them from your theory,
stop considering them, that
it's not simply the case
that you generate higher
order terms in the series.
You can also affect what you
mean by the leading order
term in the sense of changing
what you mean by the coupling.
So if I write it in
terms of Lagrangian,
I would say that the
Lagrangian for hydrogen,
if we include the
B quark, well, it's
got our proton,
electron, and photon.
And let's keep the B quark.
Alpha and MB are parameters.
If we drop the B quark because
it's giving small effects,
we just have these fields--
proton, electron, and photon.
We get a different coupling
in practice-- in principle.
So you think of this as being
a higher energy coupling
and over there alpha prime
being the low energy coupling.
There's a lot of other
things, actually,
that if you think about
hydrogen for a minute,
there's a lot of other
expansions that you've done.
Hydrogen is a very
fertile ground
for effective field theory.
So let's do that.
Let's make a little list of
what we dropped when we thought
about hydrogen. How much did
we lie to you when we first
taught you the hydrogen atom
in a quantum mechanics course?
Well, we didn't teach
you about quarks.
Why didn't we teach
you about quarks?
And the reason we didn't
teach you about quarks
is because if you think
about the typical momentum
transfer in hydrogen,
three momentum transfer,
it's [INAUDIBLE] the
mass of the electron
times the fine
structure constant.
And that's much less
than the proton size.
So the typical photons that are
involved in binding together
the hydrogen atom just have much
lower energy and they can't see
inside the proton.
They just see it as
one overall object.
And so we don't need to
know about the quarks
inside the proton.
So that was an expansion.
It's also an insensitive
to the proton mass itself.
So the proton we keep as an
object, but the mass of the--
again, the momentum
transfer, ME alpha,
is much less than the
mass of the proton, which
is of order of GeV.
And so we expand in our
treatment of the proton,
as well.
And basically what this
means is that the proton
acts like a static charge.
But proton mass wasn't
showing up in our lowest order
description of the energy here.
It would show up in higher order
corrections that we neglect.
And again, it's because
we're expanding.
And that actually affects, when
we design an effective field
theory for this situation,
how we would treat
the proton, what
type of Lagrangian
we would write down for it.
And that will be
one of our topics
is to figure out how we treat
heavy particles, like a proton,
in this case.
Another expansion that we
did is we used the fact
that the momentum transfer is
much less than the electron
mass, not just the proton mass.
And that meant that the
theory is non-relativistic
and that's why we did
non-relativistic quantum
mechanics.
If we wanted to do it as
a quantum field theory,
we would do a non-relativistic
quantum field theory.
So already in something
as simple as hydrogen,
we have here three
expansions plus many more,
thinking about the
particles that we
neglected in the description.
AUDIENCE: So the second
point [INAUDIBLE]
and the alpha, how do you know
that's not just the ratio of ME
by MP rather than ME alpha?
PROFESSOR: So--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --electron
was 1 [? GeV. ?]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So--
AUDIENCE: We would
care about it.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So in some sense, I could
have written ME here,
and that would have been fine.
If you take these together,
then of course you
could take a ratio and
you'd get ME over M proton.
The reason I wrote ME
alpha is I was really
thinking about
the momentum, sort
of the non-static
properties, the dynamics.
And the momentum of the photons,
the largest energy is this.
That's why I was
thinking about it.
But you're right that I
should write ME over M proton,
as well.
As any other
comments, questions?
So another point that I just
want to briefly comment,
which has to be true if
everything I'm telling you
is right, which has to
be true because it's
what we taught you, is that
this whole description is true
even though there's
ultraviolet divergences.
When you start doing
quantum field theory,
even if you do quantum
field theory, in this case,
for the hydrogen atom, you run
into ultraviolet divergences
where things are blowing up.
Actually, even this diagram
has ultraviolet divergences.
So before you
regulate the theory,
the bottom quark
group is infinity.
Once you regulate the
theory, it's well-defined.
And you can make
everything well-defined.
But you may worry that
this diagram seems
to be contributing an
infinite amount rather
than a finite amount.
And the whole story
goes through even
in the context of having
ultraviolet divergences.
That better be true,
because, for example,
if we had graviton loops,
they would also lead
to ultraviolet divergences.
And so we're neglecting gravity.
So it better that these ideas
of effective field theory
are not changed by having
ultraviolet divergences.
And we'll encounter that
in our discussion later on.
OK.
So that gives you
a bit of a sense
for how these ideas of
effective field theory, you've
been using them all along,
whether or not you knew it.
And we will, in this
course, flesh out
how we figure out some
of these corrections,
how we would actually
compute them,
how we would actually figure out
how to even the leading order--
what the leading
order description
of a theory in cases where we
may not know it or someone else
hasn't figured it out yet.
Those are the type of
things we're after.
Now, if you talk about the
categories of effective field
theories, if you
look at the list
that I handed out to you
or the list of things
we're going to do
in the course, then
there's really, in
general, two ways
that effective field
theories are used.
So the two ways are from the
top down or from the bottom up.
So we'll start
with the top down.
So in the top down
situation, you
know what the high
energy theory is.
I'm going to keep using
this language of masses,
where I have a high energy
and low energy theory.
And we'll think about
it more generally
when we come to examples
where we need to think
about it more generally.
So in this top-down case, we
have a high energy theory--
say, the standard model--
and that theory is
understood in the sense
that we can write down
the Lagrangian for it.
But we're not
satisfied with that.
We find it useful to
have a simpler theory
to do some low energy physics,
or even to do some high energy
physics, where not
all the degrees
of freedom of this high
energy theory are relevant.
So we're in a situation where
we have some theory, which we'll
call theory one, which is
this high energy theory
that we understand
it that we can think
about doing calculations in it.
But we want to go over to
some other theory, which
I'll call theory two, which
has less degrees of freedom.
And we're making expansions.
And that's a low energy theory.
This is the high theory.
This is the low theory.
So that's what we are in
this situation of what
we call top down, coming from
the top, from high energy,
down.
So what do we do?
Well, in this case,
it's kind of nice,
because we can actually use the
fact that we know this theory
one and can do calculations
in that theory one
to even think about
constructing theory two.
So what we can do is we could
just start calculating things
in theory one and integrate
out-- i.e. remove--
the heavier particles.
And in doing that,
we can do what's
called matching onto
the low energy theory.
That means we can
use this ability
to do calculations in
the high energy theory
to find what the operators
are of the low energy theory,
just by direct calculation.
And also if there's new low
energy constants that show up,
we can calculate the
values of those constants
by using information
and connecting them
to the high energy theory.
So in this case, we're able
to use calculations really
to construct the
low energy theory.
So just schematically, I
start with some high energy
Lagrangian and I go over to some
low energy Lagrangians where
there's an infinite series,
which I've indexed by n.
And that index is to
denote higher order
terms that are less relevant
in whatever expansion
you're doing.
So just to be
general, I'll say it's
an expansion in decreasing
relevance of the terms.
So if you're in this situation,
then these two theories
are, in some sense,
describing common things.
The high energy theory describes
more than the low energy
theory, because you've
removed something
in constructing a
low energy theory.
But the two theories have to at
least agree where they overlap.
And so they have to agree on
certain infrared observables,
which I will also often
denote as IR for infrared.
The place where they differ
is in the ultraviolet.
So they might have different
ultraviolet divergences.
Most often, they will
have different ultraviolet
divergences.
They don't have to agree
in the ultraviolet.
And actually, you
exploit that to do things
with the effective theory
that would be hard to do
with the full theory.
We'll talk about how
we do that later on.
So the fact that they differ
is actually not necessarily
a negative thing.
It can be a bonus.
And finally, you have to
ask about this sum over n.
Well, this sum
over n is infinite.
Goes on forever.
And so you have to ask the
question, when should I stop?
And therefore you have
to look to experiments
and see how precise they are,
or just to your own perseverance
and figure out what
level do you want,
what precision do you
want in your description?
So what n do you
want to stop at?
Sometimes experiment tells you
to only do the first two n's.
Sometimes you have
to decide, maybe
I only want the first one.
If you're doing it
for the first time,
I suggest you stop
at the beginning
and let someone else
to do the corrections.
This idea of doing this can
be important for separating
physics of the
high energy theory.
One example of this is in QCD.
If you take QCD for
just about any process,
there will be some parts of
it which were perturbative
and some parts of it that
were non-perturbative.
And by doing this kind of
thing where you expand,
you could construct
a low energy theory
that only has the
non-perturbative scale in it
and removes all the
perturbative scales.
If you did that, then just doing
this procedure would allow you
to figure out, what is the
non-perturbative physics
and what is the
perturbative physics?
You'd separate out, in
that case, into operators.
You'd separate out
the infrared physics.
You'd have operators built
out of the infrared fields.
And those operators
would describe
the non-perturbative physics.
And you'd have
some new low energy
constants, which would describe
the perturbative physics.
And some of the examples that
we'll do will make use of that
probably.
So that's kind of a
motivation, actually,
for some of the examples
in the standard model.
So if you think
about, for example,
integrating out heavy
particles like the w
or the z or the top quark,
one of the motivations
is sometimes what I just
said, to separate out
perturbative and
non-perturbative physics.
So that's one example.
Heavy quark effective
theory is also
an example of this top-down
effective field theory.
In heavy quark
effective field theory,
you have a field theory for the
B quark or for the charm quark
but you want to describe things
like the B meson or the charm
mesons.
Objects have non-perturbative
physics as well
as perturbative-- have mostly
non-perturbative physics.
And in order to do that, you
want to actually integrate out
the mass scale of the charm
quark or the bottom quark.
If you integrate out
the mass of the charm
quark and the bottom
quark, you go over
to something called heavy
quark effective field theory.
But it can be done in exactly
this way that I described
to you, where do you start
with the theory with the full B
quark relativistic
description and you actually
just expand and figure
out what the heavy quark
effective theory is.
So non relativistic QED
and non-relativistic QCD
are also examples here.
And soft-collinear
effective theory,
one of our main subjects, is
also an example of this type
where we can just start
in QCD, do an expansion,
and get the effective
field theory.
So what's the other category?
So the other category
is from the bottom up.
And typically in
this case, you're
interested in using
effective theory logic.
But maybe you don't know
the high energy theory.
You don't really know
anything about it.
Maybe we've never probed it.
That's one way in which
bottom-up effective field
theory shows up.
Or it could be that the
high energy theory is known
but actually doing the matching
calculations to integrate out
the degrees of freedom to do
those calculations explicitly
could be just very,
very difficult.
Maybe it would be
non-perturbative, for example.
So if the matching
is too difficult,
then you may also
want to be thinking
in this bottom-up framework
where you really just start
by thinking about
the low energy theory
without worrying about what
the high energy theory was,
or without thinking too hard
about the high energy theory,
and in particular, without doing
calculations in the high energy
theory in order to motivate
the low energy theory.
You need to know some things
about the high energy theory,
like you may need to know
that it's [? llorens ?]
invariant, that it has
certain gauge symmetry,
that it's not totally crazy.
But you don't need to
know it at the level
where you would actually
carry out calculations with it
in order to construct
the low energy theory.
Instead, you think about
the lower energy theory
from the bottom up, where
you can just devise it
based on the symmetries,
based on your power counting,
and based on identifying
the degrees of freedom.
So construct the series simply
by writing down the most
general operators
that we can think
of consistent with whatever
degrees of freedom we have,
and of course, consistent
with the symmetries
that we're imposing.
OK.
So the picture is
that you don't know
or you want to remain
agnostic about theory one,
but you still are interested
in constructing theory two.
If you do this, then
unlike the other case,
the couplings that you have when
you write down these operators,
they all are multiplied
by some couplings
if they're higher
dimensional operators
and they're not constrained
by gauge symmetry.
Then all of those
couplings are unknown.
But you can fit
them to experiment.
So the effective theory
may still be powerful
because you can make more
predictions than the number
of parameters that you
have, like for hydrogen,
where we have very
few parameters
and the effective theory, but
we can make lots of predictions
from non-relativistic
quantum mechanics.
Or it could be in
the case where you
imagine is too
difficult that maybe you
have to carry out the
matching numerically,
like with a lot of QCD.
And so that would be
another possible way
of determining couplings.
And again, the desired
precision tells us when to stop.
So it's important that we have a
power counting for this theory.
But that power counting
is in some sense defined
irrespective of what the full
theory was so that we can stop,
even in the bottom-up case.
So what are examples here?
Well, the classic
example of this type
is chiral perturbation
theory, when
you're thinking about a field
theory for kaons and pions.
And doing the matching onto
kaons and pions from QCD
is a non-perturbative
process, so you
think about constructing
the effective theory just
from low energy and
from symmetries,
knowing the symmetry breaking
pattern, in particular.
And you construct the
chiral perturbation theory
without thinking about doing
the matching explicitly.
So that's one example.
Another example of
this type is actually
the standard model itself.
If you think about
the logic that we
used when we construct
the standard model,
it was exactly this
effective field theory logic.
We said, what are the
relevant degrees of freedom?
Electron.
Quarks.
W bosons.
Listed them.
We wrote down.
We said, what are the
important guiding principles?
Gauge symmetry.
And then we wrote down the
most general Lagrangian
that we could think of.
That was the standard model.
OK, so it's an example of
a bottom-up effective field
theory.
We don't ask questions
about what's higher up.
Let me write down the
leading order Lagrangian.
And we can actually
construct higher order terms
in the standard model
expanding in the idea
that there's physics above the
scales of the standard model
and write down higher
dimension operators
and have a real standard model
that has an infinite series.
So the standard model is
an effective field theory
that has an infinite
number of operators.
And we'll talk about that
momentarily as well next time.
So that'll be the first
example we actually treat,
is the standard model as
an effective field theory.
Another example is
quantum gravity.
If you take Einstein
gravity and you
make it quantum and you
allow yourself to expand--
i.e. you say you're only
interested in low energy
physics.
So you allow yourself to
write down an infinite number
of operators.
Then you can also
renormalize that theory order
by ordering those infinite
number of operators.
And so it's also an
example of something
that you can treat from
this effective field theory
paradigm.
That was the last topic
that I would actually
be cover in this-- if we had a
couple extra weeks of lectures,
I would get to this.
But probably we won't.
So that's a topic that somebody
might pick for their project
at the end.
That's a good presentation.
OK, so important stuff.
Is there any
question about that?
Sits well with everybody,
makes them feel good inside?
OK.
So far when we've been
talking about this sum over n,
we've been really thinking
about expansions in powers.
Some mass scale divided
by some other scale
being much less than 1.
OK, that's what
we've meant by it.
But when you have two scales
like this, m and lambda,
you also get logarithms.
So it's not always powers.
There's also logs that show up.
And this comment I meant about--
that I made about
ultraviolet divergences
in the low energy
theory, it can actually
help you to understand
those logarithms.
Let's get you over here.
So when you treat
the renormalizaiton
of the low energy theory, as
you know from quantum filtering,
you have different types of
divergences, power divergences.
But the logarithmic
divergences, in particular,
are things that are playing
an important role, often,
in quantum field theory.
And in effective field
theory, it's the same thing.
Logarithms can be tied
to the re-normalization
of the low energy
effective theory
and allow us to sum infinite
series of those logarithms.
So often just the power counting
and the re-normalization
of the low energy
theory will actually
allow us not only to
calculate the logarithms,
but to think about
summing up infinite series
of those logarithms.
OK.
So that was kind
of just elaborating
on a point I made earlier.
And again, I should say
here that I've said this
in the language of there being
two masses, m1 and m2 and w
over MB.
But this is actually true
more generally again.
So I'd actually make a claim
that there's not any log
that you've seen in quantum
field theory that shouldn't
be possible to figure out an
effective field theory that
allows you to understand those
logs and predict logarithms
at higher orders in
perturbation theory.
There's not an example
in quantum field theory
that I've met that hasn't
fallen into that rubric where
some effective field theory
description allows you
to understand the logarithms.
OK.
So that's kind of a bonus.
It's not the guiding principle.
It's not what we're doing when
we're expanding in powers.
But it's something that
we get along for the ride.
And maybe it would
be the motivation
if you see some logarithms
and some process
and you want to understand them.
Maybe we would
say, well, I'd like
to understand what effective
field theory would give rise
to a description where
I could understand
those logarithms from a
re-normalization perspective.
And sometimes
that's very useful,
because maybe those logarithms
are phenomenologically
important and you want
to make predictions
about higher order logarithms,
or maybe there's controversy.
When I was a postdoc,
there was some controversy
about a term that was alpha
to the 8 log cubed alpha
in hydrogen energy levels.
8 powers of alpha,
3 powers of logs.
There was four groups.
Two of them had got one answer.
Two of them had
got another answer.
And using the ideas of
effective field theory,
we were able to figure out that
one of those groups was right
and the other was
wrong very clearly,
because you could
connect these logarithms
to an effective field theory.
And then the whole consistency
of that effective field theory
really allows you to
connect this logarithm
to other logarithms and really
to build a picture for what's
going on with the physics that
makes it totally clear what
the answer must be.
OK.
So just to give you an
example from my own past.
So let's now turn to this
question of the standard model
as an effective field theory.
So we have sum over n
and we're treating this
from the bottom up.
So we're going to
just talk about what
the degrees of freedom
are and then think
about constructing operators.
And part of the job has
already been done for us,
because I'm assuming
you have a background
in the standard model, at
least at the level of knowing
what the Lagrangian is.
And if you haven't,
then you should
look at the quantum field
theory three lecture notes.
So the L0 here is
the standard model,
as taught in quantum
field theory three.
So [INAUDIBLE] be interested
in as the higher order terms.
But let me
nevertheless remind you
of what the degrees of freedom
were in the standard model.
So you at least know
what the players are
when we go to talk about L1.
So it's a gauge theory.
So we have color across
Su 2 weak across the un
of hypercharge.
And so we have eight gluons
here, three week bosons here,
and one guy here.
So just to introduce
some notation for fields,
I'll call these guys with
an index capital A running
from 1 to 8, these
guys with an index
lower a running from 1 to 3.
And B here would be
the analog of a photon
field for U1 electromagnetism.
But this is the U1 of
hypercharge, so it's B mu.
So we have gauge bosons.
We have fermions.
Let me do the
fermions over here.
So an important
thing and thinking
about this as an
effective field theory
is to note what the
mass scales are.
So maybe I should do
that already here.
Protons are massless.
That's one combination
of the weak and U1 boson.
Gluons are massless.
That's these guys.
And then there's the mass
of the W. 80.42 GB the mass
of the Z, 91.19.
And for the first time in
me teaching this course,
we also know what the
mass of the Higgs is.
So let me just--
that's not part of
the gauge theory,
but I'll just list
it there, as well,
since it doesn't fit
in with the fermions.
So fermions-- so you can
see that these scales here
are kind of similar.
For the fermions, there's
a broad spectrum of scales.
And that's why I wanted to
put them all on one board.
So quarks-- up quarks, down
quarks, strange quarks--
they all come in left and
right handed [INAUDIBLE]
and the gauge couplings
are different for left
and right handed, for the
electroweak and U1 parts
of the gauge group.
So there are six different
flavors and both right
and left handed.
What masses do we have?
Up quarks and down
quarks are rather light,
about a couple of MeV.
It's hard to measure
the light ones.
It's a little easier to measure.
Everything's going to be in MeV.
I'm going to stop writing MeV.
Oh, that's not true.
I switched to GeV.
Sorry.
Everything is
going to be in GeV.
Oh, sorry.
That's the top quark.
OK.
So there's a pretty
wide range of scales
here from an MeV to 100 GeV.
That's just the quarks.
And then we also
have the leptons--
three types of charge
leptons, again,
with a fairly wide
range of scales.
So now I'm switching
back to MeV,
just to keep you on your toes.
Whoops.
Then we have neutrinos.
The left-handed ones
we've studied much more
than anything else.
And in particular,
what we know most about
the left-handed guys is mass
splittings from neutrino
oscillations.
And these are pretty
small numbers.
We also know that
overall, these things
are quite light, from
cosmological constraints
and otherwise.
And we don't really
know about anything
like a sterile neutrino but that
we can put bounds on its mass.
So even within the
standard model,
there's a lot of
different scales.
And if you think about it
from an effective field theory
point of view and you think
about it from the top down,
the first thing you'd get rid
of would be the top quark.
And then you'd get rid of the
W and the Z and the Higgs.
And then you would proceed down.
The next thing to go would be
the bottom quark, et cetera.
And you could think about
constructing an effective field
theory by integrating
out one at a time,
getting a new effective
field theory every time you
remove a degree of freedom.
You could take
the standard model
and expand in that fashion.
That's not the sense in which
we are thinking about it.
That would be the top-down sense
of taking the standard model
and deriving something else.
We're thinking of it here
in a different context
where we have all this stuff.
And we're actually
interested in thinking
about physics at
higher energy scales,
beyond the scale
of the weak bosons,
beyond the scale of the
top quark, the things
we're trying to figure
out at the LHC, scales
we're trying to probe.
That's the attitude in
this bottom-up approach.
OK.
So the lowest order
Lagrangian would
be the gauge sector of
the thermionic Lagrangian,
the Higgs Lagrangian.
And if we have
right-handed neutrinos,
we'd need a Lagrangian
for them, too.
So these are topics that
come up in [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm not even going to
touch them at the moment.
I can't give you a complete
review, but just a taste,
emphasizing things
that are important.
So to give you a taste, I
just write the other two down,
which are the prettier
parts, anyway.
So we have field strengths
for the kinetic terms
for our gauge bosons.
And the thermionic
Lagrangian, I can write it
as a sum over the
left handed fields--
fermion, covariant
derivative fermion.
Add a sum over
right handed fields.
Fermion covariant
derivative fermion
where this covariant derivative
is a covariant derivative
with these gauge fields.
So there's some gauge
coupling, G1, for hypercharge,
some gauge coupling, G2,
for [INAUDIBLE] weak,
and some gauge
coupling, G, for QCD.
So what is the power counting?
So we've just said what
the degrees of freedom are
and what kind of some of
the guiding principles
are-- the symmetries,
the gauge symmetry.
You learn much more about
symmetries in quantum field
theory three, so I'm not
going to go into that.
But those are basically
the guiding principles
in figuring out this L0.
What is it that we would do
a power counting in here?
So the power counting in
this bottom up approach
is related to what we left out.
So we're expanding
an epsilon here,
where epsilon is mass scales
in this standard model divided
by things that we've left
out of our description.
So in the numerator would
be things like the top quark
mass, the W mass, Z mass,
Higgs mass, all the mass scales
of the standard model.
In the denominator,
well, certainly something
like M plank is left out
of our description here.
If we had some grand
unified theory,
that goes in the denominator.
If we have supersymmetry
and we broke it,
that would go in
the denominator.
So from this effective
field theory point of view,
any physics that we've left
out of the standard model
description is anything that
generates a higher energy
scale.
That goes in the denominator.
And this is what we expanded.
So even not knowing something
about what this physics is,
we can come up with a universal
description-- a universal L1--
that describes corrections
beyond the standard model.
And what will be describing
that physics is higher
dimension operators-- operators
beyond dimension four.
But they'll be built out
of standard model fields.
So kind of from your teaching
of quantum field theory, maybe
perhaps the idea that these
two things are connected
may be clear to you,
but it's something
that we will actually cover
mostly next class, actually.
Some part of the
beginning of next class,
we'll make this connection
between the fact
that we want to expand in
that epsilon and the fact
that we can do--
in doing so, we get
higher dimensional operators.
We'll make that
absolutely clear.
That'll come next time.
So in the remainder
of today, let
me just address one
final point, and that
is the idea of what it means
to have a renormalizable field
theory.
So in our description of the
standard model that I gave
here, I mentioned symmetries.
I mentioned degrees of freedom.
I didn't mention
renormalizability.
So what does
re-normalizable mean?
So the traditional definition
of what renormalizable will mean
would be the following.
You would say a theory
is renormalizable
if at any order in perturbation
theory in this quantum field
theory the UV divergences
can be absorbed--
so there's UV divergences
from loop integrals.
If they can always be
absorbed into a finite number
of parameters, then you'd say
the theory is renormalizable.
But that's a
traditional definition.
And we will use a more
general definition here.
Certainly this was
a guiding principle
when people constructed
the standard model.
What is the effective field
theory definition of this?
It's a little more
general because it
brings in the idea of
doing power counting.
So the effective field
theory's definition
allows for the possibility
of having an infinite number
of parameters.
But at any order that
you truncate the theory,
there should only
be a finite number.
So it says that a theory must
be renormalizable order by order
in its expansion parameter.
Well, if there's more than
one, it's expansion parameters.
So even just this
sentence alone tells you
why power counting is
such an important part
of the effective theory,
because the effective theory
to make sense as a
renormalizable quantum field
theory needs to know about
its expansion parameter.
We're saying that
it's renormalizable,
that we can make
sense of the theory,
absorb all the infinities, only
order by order in expansion
parameters in general.
So it could be that you
do some calculation,
you counter some divergences.
But if they're higher
order in the expansion,
then what you need-- and you
have a power counting that
tells you that--
they would be absorbable
into some operators
that you haven't even written
down, you can just drop them.
So this definition allows
for an infinite number
of parameters that are
needed, for example,
for normalizability, but only
a finite number at some fixed
order.
Now, if you take this
logic that I just
said to you, that you could
think about things more
generally, then
you can ask, well,
what was the point of thinking
about the standard model, where
the theory turned out
to be renormalizable
in the traditional sense?
How does this fact, which is
just a subset of this case,
but an important
one, how does it
fit into this rubric
from an effective field
theory point of view?
And so the way that that
fits in is as follows.
It could turn out that
your L0 in your expansion
is renormalizable in the
traditional sense rather
than this more general sense.
And if that's
true, what it means
is that you don't see the higher
energy scales from your lowest
order Lagrangian.
So we do not know
directly about lambda
new from just looking at L0.
And that's what happens
in the standard model.
We don't really know
precisely what the high energy
scale should be
just from studying
the effect-- from studying
the leading order Lagrangian.
This will not
always be the case.
Sometimes we'll
be in a situation
where when we study the
effective theory at lowest
order in the
Lagrangian, we really
find that even in order to
make sense of that as a quantum
field theory that we need to--
that there's a scale
that gets generated
and it's part of our expansion.
And there's some terms
that we calculate
with L0 that end up being
higher order in our expansion.
And we can't
renormalize the theory
unless we actually include
higher dimension operators.
Chiral perturbation theory
is an example of that type.
And that's an example
that we'll treat.
So it's not always the
case in the standard model,
whether it's renormalizable
in a traditional sense.
That's a special case,
though it's an important one.
So questions?
OK, so hopefully this has been
partly a review of some things
that you've thought of before,
but putting them together,
perhaps in a nicer package.
And we'll continue
next time talking
about the standard model as
an effective field theory.
What can be gained from that?
How do we construct
the operators?
And we'll keep going from there.